et bonjour et bienvenue sur dia gonal tv
spéciale champion du monde allant de
topalov grands championnats du monde
avec aujourd'hui pour démarrer pour
cette première partie où topalov à les
blancs nous accueillons jérôme maufras
bonjour jérôme bonjour stéphane alors on
ne présente plus rapidement quand même
donc tu t'occupes à l'académie de
créteil du développement du jeu d'échecs
dans les écoles
salut tu es joueur de niveau
international comme tu as plus de 1000
lots et tu fais partie du comité
directeur de la fédération française
d'échecs donc très très impliqué dans
les échecs voilà je m'occupe notamment
de tout ce qui concerne le développement
des échecs dans les écoles aussi nié 1
créteil à travers ma mission que pour la
fédération au niveau national est aussi
auteur de pièces de théâtre
de temps en temps voilà de temps en
temps qui a été jouée à paris notamment
période de transfert et je crois qu'il y
en a d'autres en préparation il ya et
autres caisses en préparation et diane
informez moi un métier prolifique
puisque était aussi écrivain eu peu
d'échecs voilà donc on a on a un grand
un grand auteur multi facettes avec nous
aujourd'hui
alors pour commander ce championnat du
monde alors ce championnat du monde
topalov hanotaux pas l'offre important
donc anand
du point de vue classique convenir et le
casier le champion du monde il a battu
kramnik qu'avait battue l'espagnol
topaloff avait gagné un titre mondial
mais un peu dévoyé oui c'était pas le
titre roland classique donc là il joue
topalov pour acquérir une vraie
légitimité historique on va dire oui je
joue vraiment pour devenir le 16e
champion du monde
il a un avantage assez considérable dans
ce type de confrontation c'est qu'il
reçoit à la maison puisque le match se
déroule à sofia capitale de la bulgarie
et que anand a eu bien du mal à aller
jusqu à sofia pour disputer ce match
étant entendu que les circonstances s'y
prêtaient guère
oui alors volcan islandais à cause du
volcan islandais dont tu connais le nom
le youtube du machin et c'est exactement
ce exactement c'est le cap était et qui
qui amedi cendres dans dans l'espace
aérien et anand a été bloqué à francfort
alors lui topalov était pas bloquée
puisque c'est chez lui
donc voilà donc ils étaient bloqués un
peu ce qui fait que le match a été
légèrement décalée d'un jour par rapport
aux dates initiales bon ce qui a
bousculé un peu sans doute la couverture
du match
enfin bon sens trop trop de dégâts donc
on démarre cette première partie avec un
jour de retard
le samedi 24 avril et topalov veselin
topalov à l'eiblen pour cette première
partie de match comme on va le voir dans
les premières parties sans doute qui va
s'avérer explosif parce que on a deux
grands grands joueurs d'attaqué de bons
joueurs d'attaqué qui vont il n'y aura
pas de round d'observation
voir dans cette partie je pense que
topalov a dans l'idée de toute façon
d'avoir de grosses préparations
théorique est de prendre un nombre de la
gorge
l'histoire du volcan a fait un petit peu
monter la pression du côté d'un homme
parce que évidemment topalov à cet
avantage d'être sur place et je crois
que topalov veut tout de suite tout de
suite montré qu'ils qui donne une
psychologiquement selon elle ce sont des
duels d'homme à homme donc là on est
dans une dans une confrontation où
l'aspect psychologique est important il
topaloff est connu pour être un joueur
extrêmement agressif très tendu et qui
va au bout des parties il fait pas lui
lui le facilement c'est pas le genre et
haber nantes ce le seul pose pas de
problème si aussi un joueur qui qui aime
bien les parties tendu donc on y va dans
cette première partie
topalov allende du championnat du monde
et ça démarre par des quatre bons débuts
classique du pion dame donc ça c'est
important parce que on aurait pu voir
aussi des débuts au théâtre des carmes
on l'a cédé 4 lorsque ça sera un match
de type classique avec les joueurs qui
vont tenter de joueurs toujours les
mêmes ouverture comme c'était le cas des
grands casses maroc car pauvre où est ce
que les joueurs vont tenter plein
d'action dans le match ça on verra ça au
cours des douze parties qui composent ce
match donc cavalier six dents longues
dont c'est la réponse la plus classique
parce que la plus souple
ces quatre pour l'instant et là j'ai 6
ans assez important déjà oui oui donc là
on a un choix d'un an
g6 donc soit une estonienne qui a été
quand même abandonné depuis quelques
quelques temps qui a été un peu remis à
l'âme à la mode par radjabov ou alors la
flagrante fameuse
bonus fade alors on va voir ça la bonne
fête qui a été pratiquée par les grandes
championnes moment on va voir sa cavale
et c3 de la part de total et des cinq
mois donc c'est tout de suite si une
brune fait lé sir si on avait joué
plutôt le fond que j'essaie d'abord les
blancs auraient joué aux quatre on
n'aurait plus pu en europe peut plus
jouer ensuite des 5 et donc il faut le
jouer maintenant sinon après c'est trop
tard alors à noter que la grande fête
cette réaction centrale comme ça ici a
été jouée par les grands champions du
monde que sont fisher et kasparov
voilà deux grands champions du monde ont
adopté cette défense qui d'ailleurs joué
sur la dhr une fête soit les stand ya ni
jouer les deux fois peut-être que je me
mette pas la force de jouer toujours
pareil on se fait avoir on y va donc
c'est prendre des cinq cavaliers prendre
des 5 et l'a regardé l'idée de la grande
fête c'est que bombay après avoir pris
en d5 si on veut qu'à donc on installe
un gros centre blanc qui sera qui sera
d'autant plus renforcée si les noirs
prennent le cavalier en voilà et ils
n'ont pas trop choix dans votre circuit
le callet pas de bonnes cases
tarifs 6 il sera sous la menace de cinq
dinars est en baisse il est pas actif
donc il faut c'est changer un échange de
quoi on reprend des pions b et on a
regardé un centre très puissants
missiles
voilà des blancs alors en compensation
les noirs et bien bon éliminé de pièces
vont pouvoir mettre un fou ancien ghetto
ici et en comme idée en fait d'attaquer
ce force entre donc par ces cinq
notamment regarder derrière
comme il ya le pion c3 le fou en cas de
présence elle pourra prononcer trois par
ces 5 et pourquoi pas cette année aussi
par cinq et essayer d'en fait de contre
attaquer ce centre c'est à dire que
autant ce centre est un
un gage de l'espace dont les blancs
autant c'est aussi finalement une cible
pour les noirs c'est quelque chose à
défendre
c'est un avantage certain pour les
blancs mais c'était aussi quelque chose
qui peut être affaibli
on dit toujours qu'il faut attaquer une
structure de pion par sa base la base de
la structure de pions sont en train de
les blancs ici c'est l'option c3
soutenait un pion qui n'est pas défendu
et qui une fois qu ils se poussent
éventuellement qui disparaît ouvre le
chemin aux fous g7 vers la tour à 1 donc
qui a toujours un danger potentiel et
c'est ce que m'ont visé mais non ils
vont avoir de cesse que de d'essayer de
faire sauter ces centres blanc alors on
y va avec fougue et rouge et cède donc
la bresse et il faut se met en position
poussé quatre coups de développement
normal
d'autres possibilités mais pourquoi pas
fous ces cadres et regardez maintenant
uninor pourrir ok mais sont pas pressés
ils jouent ces cinq menace quand même
ces cinq alors évidemment les blancs ne
peuvent pas prendre pour deux raisons 1
ça casserait leur beau centre et puis en
plus de ben il ya fou princes et rois
avec et chez coran évidemment
richer coran est prise de la torah donc
on continue donc ses cinq ne prend pas
donc cavalier e 2 l'avenir dépend
logique on développe la pièce on prépare
le petit roquet en même temps le
cavalier protège tranquillement son
territoire ici les cases des 4 6 me et
ses droits
regardez les noirs ne re toujours pas
hop on augmente la pression très
classique
maintenant regardez prise en d4 prise du
fou g7 est prise de la dame des 8 ce qui
force le coup suivant puisque là les
normes menace de prendre prise brise
cavaliers prend cavaler prendre d'après
en perdant une pièce donc il faut
protéger
et voilà on est forcé de jouer le
classique fou aux trois petit roque
maintenant pour l'épauler noir donc y
ont installé une grosse pression sur ce
centre mais dans qui tient c'est c'est
un avantage long terme pour les blancs
davantage d' espaces et de contrôle du
centre petit rock et là alors je crois
que il ya eu ici quelques
discussion nous semble maintenant
puisque en fait à nantes a joué le coup
cavaliers à 5 évidemment le problème de
ce coup que l'essai mort c'est bien
certain que font ces quatre mêmes dans
un bon le câble à 5 et quand même pas
très bien placé et en est bon en plus
ils enlèvent le contrôle de la casse des
4 c'est un coût qui est assez
controversé au plan théorique ou est ce
que justement le cavalier noir se
retrouve excentré et rendent moins de
contrôles sur des quatre effectivement
on va voir par la suite dans la partie
que ce cavalier va rester assez
longtemps alors je sais pas si c'est
dans cette position toujours aussi
beaucoup g4 nous engage aussi pour que
ça existe
voilà il ya des fameuses parties caspar
wingas valroff ou un jouet 3 et après
qu'avaya siens qui comprend le faire en
faisant la grange et 4d des choses comme
ça il me semble les choses assez
compliquées mais cavaliers à 5 et un
coup clippers douteux mais qui est
controversé les comptes revient voilà
car il ya cinq ans la vie dans acal ya
cinq ans donc quand j'enlève une défense
en attaquant par don d'un défenseur mais
j'enlève l attaquant de la casse des
quatre en jouant à st eh bien le fou c4
peut revenir en d3 la dame ne protège
plus des 4 mais c'est pas grave c'est
protégé par le fou de trois ici regardez
et le cavalier 2 donc suffisant pour
soutenir le pion c3 la naissance du pion
il ya que trois attaquants et il ya
trois défenseurs donc ça tient pas de
problème et la b6 bon c'est l'idée de
cavaliers à cinq ou six c'est de jouer
bicis non pas pour protéger c'est simple
on s'en fout plus les blancs prénom c5
ce n'est pas la question puisque ça
casserait le totalement le centre mois
le centre blanc mais c'est pour avoir
une case de sortie dessous ou aussi vite
qu'ils regardent et la pat prod quasi
s'il pourrait se faire chasser par f 3
900 c'est pas pousser la corruption
ayant aussi c'est un peu maladroit
puisque tout moment on peut jouer des
cinq là qu'il faut jouer tout de suite
mais il serait quand même un
confortablement de place et c'est un des
problèmes du manque d'espacé noir c'est
qu'ils ont du mal à développer ce fou de
cazenove
donc ce fou il souvent il va enlever
cette banque on va voir ce qui se passe
alors dam des deux faux pas très bien
tranquille dans des deux très très
classique on coud très simple pourquoi
on sort la dame et bien ça permet de
lier les tours dont regardez par exemple
cette tour pourrait venir mais pourquoi
pas en c1 par exemple on mettrait la
deuxième tour en bien et puis on aurait
une action des tours sur sur des
colonnes intéressante puisque à tout
moment il peut se passer des choses de
ce côté là et puis aussi cette dame
évidemment devient soutenir le faux
trois qui peuvent venir l'a16 et
s'échanger contre en défenseur du mois
il ya le thème de l' attaque contre le
roi qui peut faire jour ce qui est
intéressant pour les blancs dans cette
configuration c'est que les cases noires
autour du roi noir sont assez faibles à
partir du moment où le fou du chantier
tôt disparu voilà donc vraiment la case
agissent exactement comme avant
d'ailleurs c'est le thème de cette
partie alors là voilà donc mon antre
ucial ou à lanzhou le coup
un peu surprenant finalement pour
peut-être si on n'a pas l'habitude de
cette variante c'est le cou aux 5 alors
que 5 alors l'idée d'un land est simple
regardez on met une pression maximale
maintenant sur le centre known as
finalement de faire définitivement
exploser le st et si les blancs n'ont
pas de compensation claire bain les
noirs où ce sont 1 libéré et 2 mais ils
ont encore une petite majorité toujours
pareil un deux contre un à la dame qui
en finale peut s'avérer même avantageuse
pour eux donc ce coup de corne et
surprenante puisque les blancs peuvent
jouer évidemment le d5 avec un pur passé
ont soutenu simplement le problème c'est
que sur des 5 et bien les noirs
pourraient continuer par ces quatre
attaquants ici se fout là donc permettre
d'éviter en fait que le pion blanc
viennent soutenir la cause des 5 et
finalement ben ce pion dessins qu'il est
certes passé mais il va être bloquée
facilement par cas mais les sept
cavaliers des 6es avec un très beau
cavalli bloqueurs et les noirs ont pour
attaquer par contre aller loin
absolument mais recevant le plan des
noirs à partir de là serait assez simple
effectivement les cavaliers sont des
très bonnes pièces pour bloquer beaucoup
plus efficace que les fous puisqu'une en
d6 lecavalier ne perd pas du tout sauf
potentiel de nuisance
il protège f5 il attaque 4 des taxes et
4 et ensuite les noirs auraient la
possibilité effectivement de pousser f5
pour pouvoir justement prendre de
l'espace et de l'expansion avait droit
oui le cavaly bloqueurs comme ça alors
je re il pourrait peut-être pas le faire
tout de suite faut d'abord qu'ils n'ont
solide soignons ces quatre ans mais un
cavalier en inde et 6 aussi a pour
intérêt nous sommes en bloc le pion
passé qui est de rendre inefficace mais
en plus ses qualités difficilement
attaquable donc c'est une pièce qui non
seulement un tas des pièces d'un camp
adverse mais protégé finalement une
sorte par ces mêmes pions adverse
ce sont les pions qui servent de
boucliers donc voilà ce qu il serait
donc faux insiste de topalov donc ça
veut dire un joueur ou assistant sur
moment crucial que topalov joule attaque
puisque là il va échanger le fou g7 et
on échange de quoi ils donnent le pion
déclarent regarder prise de deux prises
et 3 avec la dame et il y a que deux
défenseurs donc le pion des 4es perdu
donc il donne un pion topalov donc
regarder si nous avons une feuille est
une position où on peut faire des
sacrifices depuis oppositionnel ça c'est
ça c'est très important
donc c'est prend des cartes très bien
donc on échange d'angers 7
alors là le voir pour se dire je peux
reprendre bien sûr mais je pourrais
d'abord faire puis on prend ces trois
intermédiaires que ce serait une
mauvaise affaire regarder on prendrait
pas ses trois mais aujourd'hui damas six
avec simplement une pièce de plus ici
angers7
et les noirs ne pourrait pas se venger
sur le fou des trois puisqu'il y aurait
faut prendre tour avec menace de matches
derrière
et en plus cela on a des cases noires
super affaibli avec la dame elle fout ce
qui est mortelle oui donc quasiment
toutes les variantes
ça serait dur à défendre donc on ne
prend pas assez 3 mai ont fait roi
projet cette voie là et maintenant
maintenant les blancs prennent en d4 et
après je prends des quatre regarder
l'intérêt aussi pour les blancs c'est
que bombay certes y ait eu en plus pour
les noirs mais un d'abord c'est un pion
isolé un bond qui est parfaitement de
look et donc ya pas de problème etc
mais deux par contre ça libère le pion à
eux et on est le pion f qui peut donc
une petite majorité ici deux pions qui
peut aider à attaquer ce roi affaibli
par la disparition de son fou et
dernière chose ça ouvre une colonne la
colonne c'est exactement maintenant que
les changes a été fait effectivement
bien vu jérôme en d4 ici eh bien on a
une belle colonie ouverte ici pour les
blancs pour pourquoi pas pénétrer dans
plus tard et d'ailleurs c'est ce que
fait topalov torah c'est un an qu'ils
n'ont pas pressé et un top albums il met
sa tour sur une colonne ouverte elle est
bien placée
elle empêche regarder le cavalier de
revenir en c6 il aurait bien aimé ce
cavalier orient c6 et pourquoi pas venir
à 1,5 voire en 7 et angers 8 protéger et
finalement de ce droit mais il peut pas
facile mais bloqué par cette eau qui
finalement l empêche de revenir
donc on voit qu'il est mal passée album
indien il joue plus du tout ce qui
invalide d'anne decis d'un an d'alors
dam des six est important c'est empêcher
aussi des coups comme celle qui pouvait
être menaçants et bien sûr 5 subi des
quatre on tient les cases noires le foot
blanc est très actif et après des f-5
sont possibles avec des abscisses
derrière échec avec deux pions très fort
bon mais des six on veut aussi mettre la
dame pourquoi pas plus tard en scène
bien là centralisée ça peut faire
contrepoids à la faiblesse relative du
rendement non y'a rien là une critique
pour l'instant pour les noirs mais non
il ya quand même ce potentiel donc f4
avec un tournoi mais regardez donc un
deux trois quatre pions contre e3 ya un
motif d' attaques contre le roi nombre
donc ça ça lui plaît à topalov pas ce
qui est évidemment un grand joueur
d'attaqué
alors là un an de jouer 6 alors donc ça
veut dire qu'il veut empêcher sans doute
5,1 me faisait mal ça me plaisait pas
parce que sur cinq
probablement que mme après il ya des
idées comme aussi cavalli g3 cavaillé
aux 4 et 1 15 et 6 très faible on pourra
mettre un cavalier on pourrait aussi
amener la d'aborder la dame surclasse
noire pourrait vite
pénétrez avait des sacrifices de pion
par f5 donc un an de virus importants
comme manoeuvre sont assez importants
comme manoeuvre il faut bien noter que
les noirs ont un retard de développement
assez marqué un cavalier à l'abandon
fout toujours ans et 8 une tour toujours
1 à 8
ce sont des pièces qui ne joue pas alors
le fou quand même joué et jouent ils à
une action il a quand même une action
ici sur 7 le problème c'est cette tour
certes si on pouvait jouer autour de
huit tours b 7 avec l'idée de la ramener
un set c'est parfait c'est une longue
mais n'ose et l'on voit la salle ariane
de contrat tout mais les blancs de trois
coups dans le temps de faire beaucoup de
choses donc il faut effectivement faire
attention au cap 6 pour verrouiller un
peu les cases alors la fcm de topalov
qu'il y va alors ça c'est un coup risqué
pourquoi c'est risqué mais
positionnement s'y risquer regarder
parce qu'il affaiblit la case de cette
fameuse case donc la lada noir va
pouvoir venir sur cette classe c'est
d'ailleurs ce que fait attendre mais en
bas en revanche les blancs à tout moment
maintenant peuvent prendre un g6 au
moment opportun et créer des menaces
pourquoi pas contre le contre le roi
noir ont verdi aussi les possibilités
d'en mener une tour en f3 puis angers 3
par exemple pour augmenter la pression
songé 6 voire h3c pour faire une attaque
ici le regarder en conjonction avec la
dame blanche qui pourrait venir en
schiste donc on voit déjà que la
disparition de ce fou offre des déportés
opportunité de pénétration qui est assez
étonnant ici c'est qu'en jouant avec 5
bouche un petit peu l'horizon du foot
est roi voilà c'est ce qui peut paraître
un peu
étonnant dans ce cui mais aussi celui
qui fut aussi vite mais aussi celui du
fou s'est vite
donc voilà le feu sylviane ont par
exemple contre lui la case h3 voilà donc
si on la manoeuvre tourage 3 devient
possible parce qu'on a joué 25 et en
plus le foulard embellie bon d'abord ils
contrôlent les airs a cassé quatre on
sait jamais le cavalier pourra pas venir
là il empêche aussi un développement du
fou par à 6 donc on va se fout il est un
peu obligé de rester en ce 8 mai en
reste à un ses huit se fout immobilisé
la torah 8 qui jouent pas qui est en jeu
donc les larmes de pièces hors jeu quand
même un tour et cavaliers alors que
toutes les autres pièces les blancs sont
actives la tour pénétrer même en
septième éventuellement si la dame bouge
attaquant déjà faisant un échec
le foot est roi est bien placé on l'a
dit puisqu'ils contrôlent empêche à 6 et
en plus bombay protégés de 5 ce qui fait
qu'on peut jouer une manoeuvre s'ancre
être sans craindre des prisons m5 est le
cas la libye demande que en un coup de
devenir faire des sacrifices ou d où d
échec donc très vite et la dame est bien
placé donc toutes les pièces blanches
participent à l'activité
alors qu'on a au moins deux pièces noir
ici qui sont inactivées le fou ces huit
un peu un peu museler donc finalement
que deux pièces défensive d'âmes et où
comment beaucoup de pièces blanches et
des pions et les pions ça fait beaucoup
comme tout à fait quand même beaucoup
sur le roc beuron europe noire question
de style m'enfin si on est un peu
attaquants on va évidemment préféré les
blancs dans cette position même avec le
pion de - dames 5 donc la halle en
laisse et de verrouiller enjoint dame
celle d'empêcher les blondes mais
pourquoi pas de sacrifier en poussant
pions parce que c'était une possibilité
on aurait pu envisager plus tard des
cavaliers f4 ou alors des prises angers
6 suivi de5 avec pourquoi pas des
sacrifices de tous âges et si ces envois
totalement dénudés des possibilités
d'attaqué cabaye f4 maintenant de
topalov attention pression sur g6
possibilité pourquoi pas de faire un
échec en h5 même en ayant envisageant
des sacrifices par exemple avec 13,3 des
tours je crois aussi les choses comme ça
alors ici les questions ni qu ici c'est
déjà chaud pour les droits
alors là c'était peut-être temps pour un
an on va voir on va faire un coup au
tout du tout en ce moment donc c'est
déjà difficile pour un harnais le choix
qu'il a fait là pour l'instant dans
l'ouverture ce cas il ya cinq amener un
peu cette position un peu tendu on tape
alpha pris des risques mais c'est
peut-être temps pour un an maintenant
décès d'activité pièce alors une
possibilité aussi s'arrêter de jouer à 6
avec toi 7 pour un ligne tour la défense
une manoeuvre classique bon mais ça fait
bien peu les pieds noirs mais c'était
une possibilité une autre possibilité
c'est de faire jouer ce cavalier par
exemple puisqu'on peut pas venir en c6 à
cause de la tour venir ans baissaient
venir en bessette et ensuite en d6 ou
pourquoi pas éventuellement même en 18
mai en d6 en faisant pression sur f5 sur
quatre avec le cavalier qui joue et qui
quand même contrôle aussi une case
qui peut être importante pour plus tard
le seul souci du cavaliere des six et
qui permet la tour-blanche d'entrée ans
et 7
ça permet évidemment tour c'est cet
échec il faut faire des calculs mais en
venant des si on pourrait jouer tout
rêve c'est très bon on a le cavalier qui
protège on peut toujours prendre le
cavalier avec un cavalier qui devient
protecteur du roi on voit la possibilité
au lieu de quoi de jouer un coup alors
un peu douteux peut-être à mon ami
puisqu'il joue g5 alors le problème de
g5 alors l'avantagent de 2,5 c'est que
ça pose la question cavaliers mais le
problème c'est que ça affaiblit cette
case h5 et c'est ce que fait topalov ont
évidemment cavaliers h5 échec et ont
regardé ce cavalier devient énorme
puisqu'ils contrôlent la casse g7 la
case epci ce qui peut être un critère
aussi née cavallier formé il ya quand
même un verrouillage de la part des
blancs puisque dès le mardi noir pardon
parce que les pions pour l'instant
empêche une pénétration mais des thèmes
de sacrifices peuvent avoir les regarde
et on imagine très vite évidemment dh 4
4 pour casser la structure et des
pourquoi pas d'un tour f3 tôt page 3 et
pourquoi pas même des sacrifices dont
l'usagé des sacrifices les tours ses
sets sont possibles pour dévier la dame
il peut se passer beaucoup de choses et
on n'aime pas quand on défend avoir un
cavalier qui contrôle une case de quasi
matt lewis et c'est pas toujours tendu
la de laisser entrer un cavalier h5
comme ça c'est wii hd inconfortable
carrier h 55 quand on a un roi comme ça
qui n'a pas de pièce de défense ça fait
peur
ça fait plus on croit j'ai vite pour un
nombre pas trop le choix
bien sûr topalov elle a essayé de miner
c'est les dernières les dernières
défenses du roi noir ont joint la
ensuite h4 évident donc là pour
l'instant le rempart du roi noir qui
empêche
matt presque cessé ses deux pions
puisque si ce pion disparaissent et j'ai
cinq ans votre gamme à damas six déjà
maints asmat d'un machisme la smat
angers7
très vite la tour aussi peuvent venir en
f3 et g3 pour contrôler encore plus la
knesset et à tout moment des tours c'est
cette peuvent dévier la dame faire des
choses donc il faut faut quand même
avoir les nerfs solides et donc la h4
topalov effectivement attaque
cette défense là on voit ici assez
linéaire à la partie pour l'instant
c'est assez clair chaque coup les
logiques et topalov joue extrêmement
dynamique donc pas dans le consolide on
se dit c'est solide c'est solide
sauf qu'on à avancer les pions et cordes
et on aime pas quand même avoir un roi
comme ça on est tous assez vide avec un
cavalier adverse qui contrôle le cas
j'essaie de ne peut pas pénétrer mais il
suffirait mettre la dame en jet set pour
que ce soit maintenant
pour l'instant on ne peut pas pénétrer
mais si on peut faire des sacrifices
pour le faire on va pas se gêner
donc ça fait un peu peur d'être prof
mais il se pose pas trop de questions il
prend tout de suite
angers 5 évidemment alors les noirs
saurait sans doute mal inspirés de faire
f projet sec puisque alors ça affaiblit
maintenant drôlement la classe des fils
qui on peut imaginer maintenant des fils
harry 17 derrière pour la tour qui
peuvent s'avérer encore encore plus
dangereux qu'il aurait pu quand même
peut-être penser ça mais c'est quand
même très affaiblie c'est en plus ça
enlève un pion du sens à l'aise
d'options paceo blanc mais le 4 f406
philologie la dame cinq ou six
de proposer les changes les dames et
deux ans poussé 4,5 d'accord donc à
changer c'est alors là le problème c'est
qu'on a affaibli cette colonne rires oui
d'accord mais il a rien sur cette
pologne à papier ce que ça peut aller
vite à une fille de ses droits en f2 on
peut jouer le roi en f2 et la tourache
as une idée voilà je le jouais le pion
voient leurs marges et una tour où la
tour dont la tornade 3f trois virages 3
et là attention c'est quasi ça fait peur
quand même c'est pas très confortable
c'est pas confortable c'est vraiment pas
confortable d'avoir une tour comme ça
après on imagine que la dame double sur
cette colonne d'une façon ou d'une autre
par exemple par dame 2 on enlève le
cavalier d'un match 5
et c'est très difficile de parler latin
très difficile donc je prends du sègre
est d'ailleurs topalov ça me prive pas
touriste 3 donc l'idée c'est simple
c'est de tenir son g3 d'ailleurs
pourquoi pas parce qu'en jetteront
pourrait menacer des détours pranger 5
suivi de dents prend avec dé tels de
menthe très difficile apparaît très
difficile apparaît d'autant plus qu' il
y aura peut-être surcharge sur un homme
noir qui contrôle toujours la tour
l'entrée de la tour ans et 7 ans qu'elle
devra à la fois défende du mat
angers 7 et défendre la question en
échec le roi et moi ou si van f7
il y aurait une dame j'ai six échecs en
une pop et sur un roi qui va sur la
colonne âge on peut jouer ton idée c'est
à dire bonjour ou f2 et on ramène notre
tour en h1 et c'est fini on peut pas par
et le bras de quoi c'est donc ça va vite
c'est quasiment assez évident de trouver
de trouver des en tout cas les plans
apprécié alors là non on fait un coup
alors ici dans cette position ça doit
être très déjà très délicat dépend donc
on voit bien que ce cavalier qui joue
toujours pas s'il avait pu revenir un
peu en défense on était quand même un
peu soulagé mais la regarder un autre
fut un coup j'ai presque envie de
qualifie d' horrible bref c'est un
mauvais coup c'est sûr a donc il est pas
beau en tout cas n'ont peut-être pas
mauvais tactiquement au premier abord
parce qu on voit pas trop comment les
blancs peuvent profiter si on n'aime pas
ce coup pourquoi bell va d'abord c'est
un coup droit donc c'est pas super alors
il n'y a pas de menace directe sur le
roi bon ils veulent et où le roi parce
qu'il n'y a pas l'air plus ça il faut
centre en plus que là non toujours à
cause de cette tour en c1 il est
toujours sur la diagonale du fou du fou
détroit éventuellement ce oui on peut
alors imaginer d imaginer à 4 suivi de
damas deux
je jouais bien sûr à 4 suivi de
effectivement d'amano échec
regardez une belle belle diagonale vers
l'angola et jérôme bien vu puisque la
case aussi ses protégés par les pions
pour garder les pions de plus entre cet
échec à être puissant c'est très
embêtant est alors en plus qu'on n'aime
pas aussi quand on arrive en effet c'est
ici c'est que lacazette 6 est prise par
un pion et donc la case e6 est bardé ces
deux cases là sont prises par le pion et
5 ce qui fait que le roi est quasiment
dans un couloir de deuxième rangée donc
un échec futur de tours c'est cette
obligera leur bar à redescendre alors
l'autre idée daninthe peut-être c'est de
jouer tu auras schwyz et qui dit oui bon
ok mais c'est moi qui vais prendre la
colonne âge ou en tout cas essayer de la
contester à la tour à la tour sauf que
alors tant qu'on leur trouve une super
combinaisons à l'écran réussissent alors
là trop de tonnerre quand on a vu ce
coup disons sur en direct la déjà on se
dit bon c'est foutu quoi on comprend
tout de suite qu'il va y avoir de gros
problèmes si la gamme de plantes
cavaliers alors on regarde sydom prend
cavaliers qu'est ce qui se passe déjà
maintenant on peut faire entrer la tour
ans et 7 on peut éventuellement faire
entrer la torah c'est cet échec
or une autre idée c'est de jouer d'abord
torts h3 qui menace toujours autour
c'est celle est qui menace aussitôt rage
cet essai très difficile à paris alors
regardez si vous jouez dame g7 pour
empêcher tout accès tv
on est tous et cet échec et si vous
jouez un coup comme tourache 8
eh bien on peut faire tout reprend échec
et après dame prend ici on fait
simplement tour c'est cet échec et on va
loin simplement c'est par exemple ce roi
m6
ah ben ça serait matt regard des échecs
on va progresser regardé comme un roi
dénudé et facile à matin dames 1 échec
obligé d'aller par exemple en cinq dames
quatre échecs et après 3 des 6
simplement bonjour dame cet échec voix
des cinq est par exemple ici c'est le
coup c'est le coût des matches joués 4
échecs et mat
regardez comme le roi est bien mater au
centre de l'échiquier échec le roi ne
peut pas venir ici à cause du pion
latour contrôler la colonne on peut pas
bouger et la dame contrôler la classe
des six la classe
le 6 mai la classe de 5 le roi est échec
et mat donc voir décès alors c'est
typique de l'extraction en combinaison
d'extraction une mortelle randonnée
voilà donc voilà ce qui se passe ton
dame prend
alors voilà d'un prend ici pour ses 7 ou
dans ladite orages trois tours à suite
et on a vu des possibilités comme ça de
faire échec échec et le roi a vraiment
beaucoup de difficultés alors cavaliers
et 6 donc laanan joue sans doute le coup
qui tient le mieux puisque là s'il
reprend pas si fou pu ainsi reprendre
par le cavalier doit revenir en liga 2
et 2,5 et c'est archi foutu évident il
ya plus de défense contre le rat noir et
en plus on a récupéré le pion demande
donc venir la partie est totalement
finie donc il faut prendre la pièce pour
essayer de finalement de 2,2 de tenir et
de dire de dire un peu l'adversaire va
être mon sacrifice marche pas sauf que
tour h3 et voilà est déjà le problème il
n'apparaissait que même entourage cette
emprisonnerait totalement le roi un tour
échec suivi d'un projet 5 et le roi sera
totalement aux abois comment protéger
toutes les menaces
la tour qui peut pénétra tout moment d
échec
menacé à nantes joue sans doute seul
coup tu défends ce tour
alors oui il y avait un autre coup ici
intéressant c'est de la m cadre d'un f4
avait l'idée ab pour empêcher dans le
projet st on met la dame en opposition
et en plus voir dès ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'elle à tour
derrière voilà
mais sur ce coup là il y avait le
fantastique ou cinq échecs
alors si la dame évidemment reprend et
dans ce cas là et bien on peut ramener
la tour en main par exemple ici plus la
même sur dame f4 maintenant dames 2 et
regarder les pièces menace échec en
serre faut pas oublier qu'à la tour qui
peut venir agissent à tout moment et
c'est sexy indéfendable c'est totalement
indéfendable donc si on avait requis à
peu ses clichés sur l'autre coup
envisageable sur l'autre cool on va
prendre un set
encore une fois non si je vais devoir
faire non je n'en suis pas vu donc c'est
bien ça le roi prendre cinq tours ou un
échec
roi des scènes regardez comment regardez
comme c'est beau ici simplement fou et
quatre échecs avec regarder la fameuse
enfilade roi tour dans un pot même se
permettre de changer les dames et
simplement de gober la tour et on a une
grosse qualité de plus avec une finale
finalement très confortable à jouer
voire même totalement gagnante à voilà
par exemple ici si les noirs joué le
coup en plus
oui mais en plus on pourrait on pourrait
même garder les dames pour continuer la
table par exemple sur bois c5
la williams m il ya même des matins avec
de tous ses échecs et la dame après
l'avenir en b46 le roi vient en d6
mechaka la tour f 8 derrière en fait
c'est un massacre
donc c'est cette idée très joli sur dame
f4 de jouer de 5
voilà qui fait une extraction qui relève
me contre laurent noir voilà pourquoi ça
marchait pas donc la dinde jouer pour
j'évite donc la torah six échecs
attention c'est chaud il n'y a pas trop
de coups regarder ce roi g7 évidemment
ce serait dame prend du 5 et là s'est
terminé avec un match à suivre et sur
walf cet égard détourage cet échec et a
pris 3,8 qui est le seul coup ils ont
vraiment mis à diable sur l'autre
l'autre possibilité doit alors ton g7
les possibles dans ce cas là simplement
tour projet 7 puisque sur dame prend
évidemment ça y est c'est l'heure du
fameux et fumeux tour c'est cet échec et
on vend la gamme et sur europe 1 on
prend toujours g5 et l'attaqué reste
très forte
la pièce de monde compte pas pourquoi
regarder mais parce qu'elle joue pas
tout simplement s'ils mènent deux pièces
qui joue pas cercle et blanc ont
virtuellement vraiment de pièces de plus
qu'ils sont ce tour faire une pièce de
plus au moins la tour le foot se joue un
peu mais quand même il bute sur ses deux
pions l'avantagé est trop puissant et
les noirs ne peuvent pas ne peuvent pas
vraiment pas se protéger de la taca vous
pouvez vérifier chez vous testé
d'ailleurs c'est c'est mon exercice
tactique de vérifier toutes les
variantes mais c'est impossible à
défendre simplement donc tour à cette
échelle donc l'autre possibilité sinon
aussi on peut la regarder roi m6
simplement le même coup que dans la
partie tout regarder cette magnifique
paire de tours qui contrôle parfaitement
la septième en j'ai regardé le roi non
un quasi match puisqu'il n'a pas de case
la menace des blancs c'est simplement
tour h is matt
puisque le seul coup c'est ton g6 on
l'apprend nous travaillons et protéger
cette fois avec 7 est aussitôt rêve
cette mater 2 matin
succès imparable faire à moins de donner
la dame qui ont donné la dame quand on
la tourne enfin on peut pas appeler ça
des parades donc 3,8 et là bon mais
quand même tour cessé cette ward et donc
pièces de moyens mais le roi au centre à
la bande 2 tours toujours pas de
développement et ce côté là est très
très difficile voire impossible à
défendre à nantes je jouais comme un peu
parce qu'il faut quand même trouver des
coûts précis pour finir rodez vite
foulée 5
regardez alors le fouet prenat par la
dame apparemment
sauf que évidemment on va regarder
simplement sur dame prend tout
simplement seimat avec des cats
d'apprendre des quatre échecs revoir 8
force et il n'y a pas d'autres coûts
puisque sinon l'autre coup ces dames ici
mais évidemment on prend la dame on
croit ici maintenant tour échec
roy est fuite forcée et tout racheter 7
matches c'est très joli
on aurait pu faire ensuite un mail si ce
matin d'ailleurs tout marche
donc on peut pas prendre ce fou qui
n'est pas là pour se faire prendre
qui est là parce que ils menacent de
jouer des variantes à base de pourquoi
pas un échec et de sacrifier
pourquoi pas après vous prendre dans
prend et puis après on pour des échecs
ici il ya encore beaucoup de menaces
c'est un fou qui contrôle la case 17 et
la case de 8 qui peuvent s'avérer
décisive mais très vite d'ailleurs
anormaux bijoux bon ben il joue d'un
prend 1,4 bon alors il dit au moins au
pourtant ouvrir le ventre plein c'est ça
c'est ça l'idée
un dernier pour la route alors une autre
idée ces dames et trois échecs
évidemment parce que si on arrive à
éliminer la dame
peut-être on peut tenir dans nos trois
échecs au roi propose un échange de
dames
sauf que c'est aux blancs de jouer à un
très joli pour topalov pour finir tout
reprend ses 8 et échecs abandon alors
pourquoi ben non il faut quand même
regarder à regarder si tout reprend
alors c'est on prend un tour des sept
échecs ton de cet échec
le roi est obligé de venir au 8 voilà et
regardez là le fou qui quasiment fait
échec presque au roi il suffit de bouger
la tour voilà on peut prendre le pion
des 4 on peut prendre le pion des quatre
échecs et celle m
et voilà faut parer les chèques par
exemple par roy f8 et on gobe la dame
avec un avantage décisif
évidemment j'ai pas mal d'ailleurs
derrière oui oui comme les essais veut
même pas gesticuler la position donc
l'autre possibilité est la seule serwa
pardon roi prend ses 8
voilà autre possibilité est là
simplement d'un petit un échec l'insérer
leurs gardes alors si jolie alors faut
quand même être précis parce que
regarder ce qui se passe
le seul coup la menace évidemment
regardé sirois v8 évidemment c'est dans
ces sept matches sirois des huit aussi
donc sur ces deux coups dames c'est cet
essai matt puisque seront des bidons on
est mal puisque le fou contre la casse
de 8 ans b 8 la torah 8 en plus la voix
de bouger ces matières est donc le seul
coup qui tient ces carrés c6 mozilla
peut peut-être tenir pourquoi parce que
fo prend ses six mètres
voilà ça colle à la menace attaque la
dame mais aussi la tour si la dame bouge
d'important par exemple je sais pas moi
en 5
on prend la torre 8 avec échec de la
dame laura bush et ses maths est pareil
la même idée donc seul coup ici c'est de
tenter dans les trois échecs à me
changer d'âne et j'ai quand même bon
mais en fait regarder après d'en prendre
trois forces et puis on prend on prend
la torah 8 et on a une pièce de plus en
finale
vous me direz il aurait pu jouer ce
match niveau là vu la position parce que
bon
il ya trois pions contre 4 mais en fait
le plus étroit a quasiment perdu déjà
puisqu'il trop avancé le roi blanc va
aller le cueillir facilement avec l'aide
de la tour la pièce de plus suffi
évidemment à ce niveau-là de jeu entre
deux champions du monde à gagner cette
finale facilement donc anand abandonne à
juste titre après le magnifique tour
construite sans même jouer les quelques
coups qu'il aurait pu tenter par la
suite très belles parties de topalov et
on peut dire qu percuté carreaux
d'entraîner à huy
en tout cas à risques de chaos d'entrée
à nantes se retrouve presque au tapis
c'est dur de commencer en championnat du
monde avec un point de retard comme ça
après être arrivé difficilement jusque
jusqu à sofia il a été cueilli à froid
est ce qu'il aura une réaction de grands
champions ou est-ce qu'il va essayé de
temporiser dans la deuxième partie pour
reprendre ses esprits
on verra ça plus tard on verra ça les
vendeurs tu va nous rejoindre à la
deuxième émission absolument augmenter
aussi avec nous cette deuxième partie de
ce championnat du monde qui démarre sur
les chapeaux de roue allende topalov un
très très beau match
merci de nous avoir suivis et puis
continuer à nous être fidèles sur
diagonale télé merci au revoir
bien servi